starlink is basically satellite internet
service that is supposed to make
high-speed internet available
everywhere around the world for a
reasonable price aside from bringing
internet service to even the most remote
areas
the main purpose of starlink is of
course to help fund mars
but given the massive initial investment
spacex had the front to even make
starlink possible
how long will it take for starling to
become profitable and how much funding
will it generate for mars
well let's take a look at how much it
will cost spacex to even get starlink up
and running in the first place starting
with
launch cost a major advantage for spacex
when launching starling satellites
is that they can do it themselves they
don't need to rely on a third-party
launch provider to get their satellites
into orbit
and this saves them tens of millions of
dollars every single launch elon musk
has previously revealed that it costs 15
million
to launch a falcon 9 with a reused
booster however
spacex charges commercial customers
about 50 million per falcon 9 launch
with a reused booster
so being able to conduct their own
launches cuts down their launch cost
multiple-fold
i think spacex tries to stick with reuse
boosters when launching starling
satellites
but problems do occur here and there for
instance just a couple of weeks ago
a falcon 9 booster fell into the ocean
when trying to land on the drone ship
so when we calculate launch costs of
these falcon 9s
we do have to account for errors and
unexpected issues that happen from time
to time
to account for this we'll say that one
in five starling launches cost as much
as launching a brand new falcon 9
which comes in at 50 million dollars
this should account for the cost of
scrubs and the cost of unexpected
repairs and
any other miscellaneous expenses that
come up as well if we average that in
we get an approximate launch cost of 22
million dollars per starling mission
moving on let's take a look at how much
the starling satellites themselves cost
we don't have an exact price for each
satellite but spacex has previously
revealed a price range
at the end of 2019 they revealed that
each starling satellite already cost
less than five hundred thousand dollars
however their goal was to get this down
to 250
000 hopefully they do achieve this goal
but to be conservative we'll say that
the average sterling satellite ends up
costing a little more at three hundred
thousand dollars
that should account for the dead
starling satellites that spacex has here
and there
with each strolling mission spacex
launches roughly 60 strolling satellites
into space
meaning that each payload costs
approximately 18 million dollars
if we add this to the cost of launching
the falcon 9 itself we get a price of 40
million dollars per stolen mission
however simply manufacturing the
satellites and launching them are not
the only costs involved in setting up
starlink
we also have to account for the cost of
actually developing and upgrading falcon
9 as well as the satellites themselves
there's also the cost of getting
licenses to launch the satellites and
monitoring the satellites after they're
in orbit
fortunately for spacex i think they've
subsidized most if not all of their
falcon 9 research and development costs
using commercial contracts
and as for the development of the
satellites themselves this
is really not too complicated it's not
like they're trying to land boosters or
belly flop starships when they're
designing the satellites
as a result these additional expenses
shouldn't add too much the cost of the
mission
but what caught 10 million per launch
just to be on the safe side
adding everything together we get a
final launch cost of 50 million dollars
per strolling mission
if we divide that by the number of
satellites in each mission we get a cost
of 834 thousand dollars per satellite
spacex plans to keep each starling
satellite in orbit for four to five
years before
deorbiting and replacing them since
we've already been conservative
everywhere else
we'll say that spacex keeps these
satellites in orbit for five years
that means that each satellite costs 167
thousand dollars per year
or a little less than fourteen thousand
dollars per month at this point if we
figure out how many customers each
satellite can support
we can figure out how much a cost spacex
provides service to each customer
and how much it will subsequently profit
unfortunately
spacex has now revealed how many users
each satellite can support
but we can estimate this based on how
many satellites they plan to launch
and how many customers they plan to
support in total in august of 2020
spacex requested permission to support 5
million customers using starlink
at the time they had permission to
launch 12 000 starling satellites
meaning that they were planning for each
satellite to support about 416 customers
dividing the monthly cost of running a
satellite by the number of customers it
can support
we get 33 per month adding in another
two dollars to account for customer
support and cancellations
we get about 35 per month per customer
currently spacex is charging 100 per
month per customer
however i think this is mainly because
they haven't been able to take advantage
of economies of scale
just yet right now they only have 10 000
users total
so their operation is no doubt in the
red by quite an amount
as they go to millions of customers
though i suspect the lower the price to
a month and they'll likely add a 60 a
month option that comes with lower
speeds
considering that starlink will mostly be
used by people living in rural areas
i think it's likely that most of them
will be more than happy with the 60
offering nearly everyone with tech jobs
that require high speed internet
connections live in
or around major cities and a lot of
these tech hubs already have fiber
internet availability
so i'm not sure how many of these people
will consider starlink
but to give spacex the benefit of the
doubt we'll say that there's an even
split between people buying a 60
subscription and the 80 subscription
this means that spacex's average
long-term
revenue per customer is 70 a month
subtracting the 35
dollar cost spacex to actually provide
the service spacex is left with a profit
of 35
per customer per month when launching
with falcon 9's
spacex is eventually planning to
transition over to launching with
starships
which will not only significantly reduce
launch cost but also significantly
increase payload capacity
spacex is making rapid progress in terms
of starship development
but even at this pace it's likely going
to take until at least the beginning of
2022 to start doing consistent launches
with starship
more realistically we're probably
looking at 2023 or 2024
so for the first phase of strolling
deployment we'll say that spacex
primarily uses falcon 9s
spacex aims to launch a total of 4 425
starling satellites by 2024
right now they already have over a
thousand satellites in orbit
and even completing just two strolling
missions per month like they have been
doing would be enough to reach this goal
if each satellite is able to support 416
customers like we previously discussed
spacex could support about 1.84 million
customers by the end of 2023.
at 70 a customer spacex would pull in
128.8 million
per month in revenue and 64.4 million
dollars per month in profit
on an annual basis that translates to
1.55 billion dollars in revenue
and 773 million dollars in profit
subtracting 20 for taxes
we get a net annual profit of 618.4
million dollars
if spacex does decide ipo the starling
portion of their business
we'd likely see a super high p e ratio
of 30 40
50 or even 100 but if we're talking
about a fair grounded value
i think 15 is a good p e ratio keep in
mind that though starlink is helping
fund starship
starlink itself is really just an
interest service provider at the end of
the day
so at a pe ratio of 15 starlink would
boast a market cap of 9.276 billion
or about 10 billion by 2024 but
what about after spacex starts launching
using starship
well everything we discussed so far
would remain the same except for the
launch cost of each rocket
and the velocity at which spacex is able
to deploy satellites
elon musk's long-term goal for starship
is a launch cost of just
two million dollars let's not forget
that starship will also have over four
times the payload capacity of falcon 9.
clearly this is definitely a super
ambitious goal and
i truly hope they're able to achieve
this but for this video
we'll use a price of 5 million a launch
as that seems more realistic
i hope elon proves me wrong though
anyways
this would subsequently knock off 17
million from the launch cost of each
darling mission
bringing it down to 33 million dollars
meanwhile the cost of the payload will
increase more than threefold
and starship will be able to carry 250
satellites if not more
at 300 thousand dollars a satellite each
payload will boast a value of 75 million
dollars
that's 57 million more than the falcon 9
pillowed increasing the total mission
cost to 90 million
at this point though we can divide by a
much larger denominator which will
significantly bring down the cost of
each satellite
dividing 90 million dollars by 250
satellites we get 360 thousand dollars
per satellite
spreading that over five years we get an
annual cost of seventy two thousand
dollars
and the monthly cost of just six
thousand dollars with 416 customers per
satellite
we will only cost spacex 14.42 to
support each customer
accounting for any miscellaneous costs
we'll call it 15 per customer per month
as for how many customers spacex can
support each launch of 250 satellites
will add 104 000 in terms of customer
capacity
if spacex sticks to about two launches
per month they would be able to add
about 2.5 million more customers
every year given that their satellites
have a lifespan of four to five years
spacex could grow to about 10 to 12
million customers pretty naturally
if they really focus on growing a
satellite internet business i'm sure
they can grow to tens of millions of
total customers
but we have to keep in mind that spacex
is using starlink as a method to fund
mars
while helping people with poor internet
they're not trying to compete against
att
or spectrum so we're going to say that
spacex simply maintains their customer
base
once they reach 10 million customers
which should be possible by the end of
this decade
in the latter half of this decade though
it's likely that amazon and blue origin
satellite internet offering will also be
up and running
thus spacex will have some competition
this combined with even cheaper launch
costs will likely display sex lowering
prices for those services
maybe instead of charging 60 and 80 a
month spacex will charge 40 and 60
a month in such a scenario the average
customer would pay about 50
per month with 10 million customers that
comes out to 500 million dollars per
month
and 6 billion per year in revenue
subtracting spacex's cost
we get 350 million dollars per month and
4.2 billion dollars per year
subtracting another 20 for taxes we get
a net profit of 3.36 billion dollars per
year
again applying a pe ratio of 15 you get
a market cap of 50 billion dollars
in the long run spacex might push it to
15 or 20 million customers
but i don't think they'll go much
further than that so at the end of the
day
starlink is capable of net profiting up
to 7 billion per year
being worth up to 100 billion dollars do
you guys think that's reasonable
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited for the future
of starlink
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one